INTERVIEWER: Parasitic
diseases like malaria, loa loa,
and river blindness effect
billions of people every year.
In 2015, 3.2 billion people
were at risk of malaria alone.
That's half the
world's population.
In order to save lives,
quick diagnosis and treatment
is crucial.
But that's not always possible
for those most affected
by these diseases in
the developing world.
But that could all change thanks
to a modified piece of tech
that we already know and love.
MATTHEW BAKALAR: We
build microscopes that
are based around a cell phone.
INTERVIEWER: That's Matt
Bakalar, a bioengineering Ph.D.
Student at the University
of California Berkeley.
He's part of a
project team that's
been working on the CellScope
Loa, an optical device that
converts a cell phone's camera
into an inexpensive handheld
microscope.
MATTHEW BAKALAR: So the
way this works is you slide
the phone into the holder here.
And then we run an
app, just like you
would if you were loading
up Facebook or Gmail.
The operator would
take somebody's finger,
prick their finger, and then
load a small volume of blood
directly into this
glass capillary.
Then all you do
is you insert this
into the side of the device,
and you can begin a test.
What we'll see on the screen is
a magnified image of the blood.
And when everything looks
good, we just press go,
and the test will begin.
INTERVIEWER: During
the test, the device
captures five-second
video clips as it moves
across the magnified sample.
CellScope's software
then scans each clip
for irregular movement caused
by parasites in the blood.
Unlike traditional
microscopic analysis,
which could take
days or even weeks,
the CellScope test
takes just 30 seconds,
meaning that if the
software detects a parasite,
the patient could be
diagnosed and given treatment
almost immediately.
This is really amazing.
This is a cell phone
that so many people
have that can diagnose
you for loa loa
or a number of other
different diseases.
Is that correct?
MATTHEW BAKALAR: Yep.
So this device itself only
diagnosis for loa loa.
But its devices that
look very, very similar
to this that can work on
other diseases as well.
Anything that you can
see with a microscope,
you can see with this.
INTERVIEWER: The team is betting
this technology will be a game
changer, in places where
visiting a hospital
can be difficult, expensive,
and time consuming.
Do you have to have somebody,
a trained pathologist,
look at the results on the phone
to determine what's going on?
Or can the average
person find out
if they have say TB or malaria.
MATTHEW BAKALAR: Right,
so that's the great thing
about the device.
So we've taken a job
that was typically
done by a trained
pathologist, and we
do that instead with software.
INTERVIEWER: I met with
Professor Dan Fletcher, who
explained how CellScope
was born from a project he
set in his optics class
several years ago.
DAN FLETCHER: The
challenge to the students
was, can you convert
this mobile phone
camera into something that takes
a picture of a blood sample?
The trick was, you couldn't
change what was in the phone.
INTERVIEWER: When the
students first started,
they were innovating using
cell phones with limited optics
and software capabilities.
But in a short span
of time, and thanks
in large part to consumers
demanding better cameras
and faster processors,
cell phones
have gotten a lot smarter.
MIKE D'AMBROSIO: The
development both of the hardware
and of the entire
infrastructure that
allows us to run great
software on the devices
has enabled our prototypes
to go from really
rudimentary microscopes
all the way to integrated
medical diagnostics, which are
used to treat tens of thousands
of people in Cameroon.
INTERVIEWER: And the team
has been fortunate enough
to see firsthand the
impact the CellScope has
had in Cameroon, where for
many, the cost of seeing
a doctor in a hospital
is simply out of reach.
MATTHEW BAKALAR: So I was
very nervous in the beginning.
And then you start to see
the first few patients
running through,
getting their results,
and really smiling and
being happy about it.
I think the fact that they
were included in the diagnosis
really makes a difference.
So rather than taking some blood
and sending it off to a lab,
you really feel
like you're there
doing something
that's worthwhile,
spending your time
making a difference.
So it's great to see
a piece of technology
that you've engineered
perform in the field.
But this is different than
what we would normally
do in science.
Here, we're actually interacting
with people who are directly
benefited from this technology.
MIKE D'AMBROSIO: So a lot
of people these days carry
around these mobile devices.
And it's not really in
the front of your mind
how powerful this device is.
INTERVIEWER: After learning how
many lives the CellScope has
already managed to
improve, it's mind
blowing to think how many other
life changing innovations could
be developed around a piece of
technology that so many of us
take for granted.
William Tarpeh is another
scientist at Berkeley
who's created a
groundbreaking innovation.
Watch this DNews
episode to learn
about how he's turning pee
into fertilizer to help
feed the world.
We want to take a moment
to thank our partner,
the Blum Center for
Developing Economies
at the University of California
Berkeley, an innovation
and research hub that's tackling
issues in global poverty.
Make sure to check out some
of their incredible work
by visiting
blumcenter.berkely.edu.
Thanks for watching,
and please don't
forget to subscribe
to "Seeker Stories".